- What's up Believe Nation?
I'm a little bit sick today
it's been a really rough week
but this is the last video
I need to make for the week
so I'm going to bring everything I have
to this final video as we
talk about the seven ways
to get started in your
business with zero cash.
(techno music)
So one of the most common questions
that I get asked on my stream,
in my emails, on twitter,
on YouTube is how do I get started?
I don't have any money.
I don't have an investor.
You need money to make money.
You don't.
I'm going to show you how to
do it in seven different ways,
how you can make money
and start a business
without any start-up cap.
Here we go.
Okay so way number one is start a service.
I think entrepreneurs should
always start at the service
over a product whenever possible
'cause it does a couple things.
One, when you start the service,
you don't need to invest into any gear,
you don't need products,
you don't need a location.
You can go to your clients.
You're investing your time,
your energy, your hustle,
but you're not investing your dollars.
So it's a great way to get
started and test something out
before investing money into it
and as you start making money
then you can put it back in.
So start with a service.
The other thing that it
does with a service is
that it gets you close to your customers.
When you're selling a product,
you're not as close to your customer
but when you're doing a service
and you're meeting with
them, whether it's every week
or every month or every
quarter, whatever it is.
You're getting close to them ,
you're getting to understand them.
So you're getting their
money which is great,
you get cash still coming in without
spending anything and
you're getting close to them
so you can understand their needs
and when you're ready to make
the jump and sell product,
you have a ready base already there.
So you can get that attachment to them
and when you're ready to go bigger,
you already have that base to build from.
Number two is use a
print on demand service.
If you are going to any kind of product
make sure that it's a
limited production run
and that you're not
outlaying tons of cash.
This is a big mistake that
a lot of entrepreneurs
will make when they're
first getting started.
If you want to make caps, right.
I'm going to make caps, I want
to be in the cap making business.
Great I've got this sick design
that's going to take off.
Awesome.
If you want to make real
margin off of baseball hats,
you need to order tons, right,
you need to have 10,000.
You need to order 5000, 10,000.
The challenge is one that
costs a lot of money,
you're going to have
to take out a big loan
or take a mortgage on your house
or sell everything you have.
To get the start-up capital to be able
to make the initial purchase.
But the problem is you don't know
if that's going to sell or not.
And it happens to so many people,
they go for the bulk order
'cause they get the biggest price breaks
and you figure if I can
sell all 10,000 of these,
I'm going to make it rich, great.
And then you sell three.
Because maybe your design sucks,
because maybe you wouldn't like it enough.
And so I would much rather you
use a print on demand service
where you are selling one hat at a time
and they're being
printed one hat at a time
and being shipped one hat at a time
And there's services
that allow you to do this
for a huge range of products.
Whatever you're tryin'
to get out there and sell
and why it's great is you're
not spending any money.
The downside is you're
not making as much money,
right, where if you buy 10,00 caps,
you might be making a 90% margin.
Where if you're selling one cap at a time,
you may be making 5% or 10%,
you're not making as much
but what it allows you to do is test.
What I would love to see you
do if you're going into caps
or t-shirts, whatever
you're trying to make,
test your concept, see if it works,
see if people want to buy it or not.
And if you're selling these caps
and your selling hundreds
and hundreds of caps,
then you can say you know what,
forget this print on demand service,
I'm going to take the
money that I made from this
and I'm going to make my own order.
Now it's worth it.
It's not risky because you
already have a ready audience.
You know those are going to keep selling
so use the print on
demand service to start,
to test it, to build up an audience,
and then when you're ready, make the jump.
'Cause what I don't want you to do
is take out a big mortgage
and then get stuck with 9992 caps,
sittin' in your mama's basement,
'cause you couldn't sell
them and you took your shot
and now you're in debt
for the rest of your life.
Don't do that.
Use a print on demand service.
Number three is barter and borrow.
Listen as an entrepreneur it's never
about the resources you have,
it's always about how
resourceful you can be
and so think about what you can barter,
think about what you can trade,
think about what you're really good at
and what you need help with
and maybe you could trade
what you're really good
at with somebody else
'cause they need help with that.
If you're lawyer trying to get started
but you need a website,
trade some legal services
to a website designer.
They'll build you a website,
you got your legal services.
Whatever it is, there's
people who need what you have,
and you need what they have
so find some way to barter.
As an example, after I
sold my first business,
I needed a new office, I
needed a new thing to do
and so I connected with
a venture capital company
and they had this amazing
office at Yonge and King,
which in Toronto,
is one of the most prestigious
addresses you can have
pretty much in the country
actually, in Canada
and I was there and I
got the space for free
and I got to incubate my
next company out of there
because I was able to
barter with the people
who owned that business.
I joined them, I helped
them bring in deals
at the same time I got to
incubate my business out of it
and so look for people
who have what you need
and how you might be able
to work some kind of trade.
The other thing is to
borrow, before you go out
and buy something, borrow from somebody.
You get a landscaping deal great
but your first gig don't go
out and buy all the gear,
go borrow the gear from
one of your friends
that's sittin' in their garage
and they're not using it.
When I was gettin' started on YouTube,
I did both, I did barter and I did borrow.
I had a friend of mine Mark Drager,
who's actually featured in Your One Word
was startin' at this
company Phantom Media,
he came in and in exchange for promotion
on the channel, he filmed my videos.
So some of my very first
videos has this intro,
created by Phantom Media or in association
with Phantom Media, whatever it is,
he got a lot of exposure on my channel
and in exchange he did
the video production
and I was just the guy
in front of the camera
and so that was a great exchange,
as I wanted to go off and do it myself,
the next step before I bought a camera
was I borrowed a camera
from a buddy of mine.
He was a bartender and
he did bartending tricks
and flare and he filmed a
whole bunch of his events
and I said hey can I borrow your camera?
Would you mind, I want to make
my own YouTube channel
videos and see what happens
and I borrowed his camera for a day.
Borrow don't go and buy yet, borrow, test,
always find a smaller way to get started.
In almost any industry there's
a smaller way to get started.
Go out and find that and then
pour it into your business.
You look at Toronto Dance Salsa,
yes I have a retail location now.
Yes it cost me six
figures in rent every year
but how the business was started
was renting spots out of gyms
where we would pay 25,
30, 40 dollars an hour
to rent their gym space for an hour
and then fill it with students
and then we did more time,
two hours, three hours at a
time and then multiple days.
If you want to start a bake
shop, you don't have to go out
and take a five to ten
year lease on a bake shop.
Find somebody who already
has some retail location
and ask if you can have a
tiny part of their store.
Come in for one day or come
in for everyday for a week,
come in for every Saturday for a year,
they take a piece of
every sale that comes in
or whether they like it
for just the marketing
'cause you're bringing in awareness
and people to the store.
There's always a smaller
way to get started.
Borrow, barter, think
smaller, think bigger
at the same time, big goal, crunch it down
into the next immediate
steps, because what happens,
happens to a lot of you,
you have this big goal
and you think you have to
take this huge giant step,
that's my next step, I
got to open up my store,
that's my next step, I got
to take that big order,
that's my next step
and then you do nothing
because you can't get the capital
and so you stay here at the
bottom having done nothing,
and then years and years and years go by
and you see other people
makin' tons of cash
off of your idea and you
freak out and complain
and say that was my idea,
I should be the one
making money off of that.
No 'cause you didn't take any action.
'Cause the idea alone is not enough,
you got to do the work
and so stop tryin' to take that big step
and instead doing nothing,
small steps will lead to that big step.
There is always a smaller
way to get started,
go find it and stop making excuses.
Barter and borrow.
Number four is pre-sell
and the idea here is,
use services like Kickstarter
or use an email list
or use Facebook or whatever it is
and start to pre-sell your idea.
Whatever product, whatever service,
whatever you have in your mind
that you think might cost
you $10,000 or $50,000
or whatever it is you think
it's going to cost you,
make a video about it,
make a web page about it,
you can do it yourself,
it doesn't have to cost you money,
you're partnering with people
to help make that happen,
and pre-sell it so before
you actually go out
and write that book or before you go out
and make that t-shirt,
or before you go out
and launch that service,
you can pre-sell it
and see if people are willing to buy it
and actually put money
down and say listen,
if I get a hundred people who
will want to buy this book,
I am going to write it
and here's the topic.
If I get a thousand people,
who will pay for this specific e-book,
then I'm going to write it.
Or whatever it is, whatever
your product idea is,
this new baseball hat,
if I get 25 people to
commit to the first order
of my baseball hat or a thousand people,
whatever it is you need
to make your numbers work,
that's the whole point of Kickstarter,
it's great 'cause you're
not givin' up equity.
Remember when you're going to an investor,
you're giving up equity in your business.
Here it's just marketing,
if you don't hit the goal,
you don't make the product.
I mean it sucks, 'cause
you didn't make the goal,
but it's great
because you didn't outlay
thousands of dollars
on this idea that's not going to take off.
'Cause you don't have an audience for it
so pre-selling is a
great, great, fantastic,
amazing way to launch your business
without having to spend any money.
Number five is use free resources,
just like bartering and
trading and borrowing,
I like free too.
I like finding free ways to do stuff
and so I would always look to free,
even if it's not ideal,
I would look to free before
paying for something.
I want to start it, get
anything up, test it,
and then as I start making some money,
then I invest it back into growing.
As an example there's this
great games cafe that opened up
in Toronto where you pay
five to 10 dollars to get
into the location and then you play games
and then they sell food
and it's a coffee shop
and it's a bar and they
have multiple locations now.
When they started, it's
called Snakes and Lattes
instead of Snakes and
Ladders, Snakes and Lattes.
Anyway when they started,
they didn't have a website,
instead of investing
into a website they
just did it on Facebook.
They did everything on Facebook.
Facebook has all of the social connections
all built in already ready to go.
When you're starting you
don't need a website.
Does it help you?
Does it make you look more credible?
Does it allow you to do
more customized things?
A hundred percent.
But you don't need it.
Start on Facebook just
start get something up.
Get some attention, get some traction,
get your first dollars in
and then once you start making some money,
you can figure out okay where
am I going to spend that?
I'm going to spend that
on improving my product,
I'm going to spend that on business cards,
I'm going to spend it on an office car.
Am I going to spend it on a new website?
Where am I going to spend it?
When you're meeting people
you don't need an office
Having an office should never
be anything you consider
until you're making some money.
Meet people at their location.
Meet people in Starbucks.
I still meet people at Starbucks.
I like getting out of the office.
You don't need to have an office.
Stop finding ways to spend money,
anybody can spend money,
anybody can put a budget together
and say hey I need a million
dollars to go and do this
and here's how we're going to spend it.
Amazing.
I'm sure you could find millions of ways
to spend a million dollars,
you'll figure it out.
Anybody can spend money.
Not everybody can make it.
So find ways to go free
like using Facebook,
like not having a business card,
like not buying office
equipment, any of that stuff,
go to coffee shops until
you're making some money.
Number six is turn your job into a client.
I've always been a big
proponent of if you're
going to have a job,
don't look at it as just
having an income source,
yes you need to make money and it's great.
You need to be learning from your job,
the point of taking a job is to learn,
so whatever business you want to get into,
whatever this new company
you want to start,
the ideal scenario is
to find somebody who's
already done that and go work for them.
Find somebody who has 10 employees,
some small company whose
built up, is bigger than you
but not some giant where
the job you're going to get
is tiny and not helpful
and then go work for them to learn.
Yes get paid but to learn.
So how do you transition
that job into a business?
The two things that come to mind are one,
that company that you're working for
could become your first client.
It happens a lot,
where you need to free
up some on your time,
you don't want to be an employee anymore
and so you become an
independent contractor
where instead of going
to work five days a week,
you work three days a
week or two days a week
or one day a week,
and maybe it's not from
the office anymore,
maybe you work from home
and you're not an employee,
with the benefits and
all the taxes anymore,
you're an independent contractor
running your own company
and so it gives you some money,
it gives you your own client
and you're in business.
The second way to do it is to
use some of the opportunities
that come through this
business that you're working at
for your own advantage.
So you might be able to
take one of the clients
that you're working on
or you meet somebody at a networking event
because you're going there,
you're forming contacts,
you're forming partnerships,
by being in the space you
get to make connections.
You may see an opportunity for,
you go to this networking
event and there's this person
that you meet and there's
an opportunity for you
to work with them, for
them to be your client.
So you bring them on board
and that could be your
first client as well.
Either from becoming an
independent contractor
and splitting up your week,
so you're not spending
full time at your job
or using the connections that you build
which is why it's so
important to have a job
in the industry that you want
to build your business in,
you're making contacts and
from there one of those
become your first client.
And the number seven and
final way to build a business
without having to spend any cash,
and it's an important one,
build around a customer.
Business is about providing value
and I've talked a lot, a
lot, a lot, a lot, a lot,
about this on this channel
if you want to make money,
you have to provide value to your clients.
Having success in
business is going to come
from combining two things,
this is how you're going to provide value,
in this corner, in this
fist is what you love doing.
This is your passion, this
is what you love doing
and in this corner, in this
fist is what the market wants,
what your clients want,
your success will come by
bringing these two together
because if you love doing something
but it provides no value to anybody else,
it's going to be a hard time
becoming a successful entrepreneur
and if all you're doing
is chasing opportunity,
but you're not interested in it,
you're never going to really be a success,
you may make a few bucks but
you're never going to really
be a successful entrepreneur.
So you need to combine what you love doing
with what people will pay
for with the market wants.
There's been a ton of video
series that I've put up
that I love doing but you
guys didn't resonate with
and that I pulled down.
Some I do keep up but recognize
that this is really just for me
but if I had to build my
whole channel around it,
it wouldn't work.
There's been other ones
that I could easily go to,
if I put 10 stupidest things
that Steve Jobs ever said,
10 biggest fights with Donald Trump,
if I started doing those kinds of videos,
people would eat that up,
they might be the most
popular videos on my channel,
people would love that
but the idea of putting people down
and making people look stupid,
and just causing controversy
for the sake of fighting,
I don't like it at all.
I never want to do that stuff
it's not part of who I am
and so I'm not making
those videos even though
there is a demand because other people
would do a better job
at it anyway then me.
I don't want to play in that game.
And so combining what you love
with what the market
wants is super important
and that's why you need to get
close to potential customers
and build a product or service around them
so instead of just saying here's my idea,
go buy or don't buy.
Be more collaborative.
Think about who potential customers
would be for your service
of for your product
and go out and talk to them
ask them what they think,
ask them what their needs are,
ask them what their problems are,
ask them what their pains are
if I made this for you, or
I came and did this for you
would it help would that be
something that you would pay for
is that enough value for you?
If you get a yes and it's work
that you would want to do,
then you're in business and If not
then you need to keep talking to people,
keep meeting people, make a list
of all the potential customers,
these are the kinds of
people who would buy from me
and go understand them.
So instead of just selling them something,
instead of just saying here
is a solution for you ,
it's talking to them and
building a business around them.
This is something I did really
in my very first business,
even in this business, look the top 10's,
most of the videos that
we make on this channel
are your requests, like what
do you guys want to hear?
Who do you guys want
us to make a video on?
What topic do you want to hear from?
We collect it, we think
about, we pick the ones
that we like the most too and
then we start running with it.
In my first business, the
biotech software company,
all of the features that we built ended up
being around what are customer's wanted.
You know you want this
thing added to the software,
great it's going to cost you
this amount of money to do it.
And then we roll that
feature into the software
for everybody else as well,
to get some custom development,
we're not out money
on the development,
and then we can roll it out
for everybody else as well.
You want it translated into Spanish?
Perfect it's going to cost
this amount of money to do it,
provides enough value to
them even if that alone
is break even,
even if you're not making
a profit off of that,
we can roll it out to everybody else
and add more value to them.
Building your business around
a customer is so, so, so, so
important especially in the early days.
So those are my seven ways
on how to start a business
without having any cash.
I'm curious what do you guys think?
What was you favorite rule?
What resonated the most with you?
What are you going to
take from this and apply
to your business immediately?
Did I miss something that you want to add?
Is there eight, nine, 10 that
you want to add to the list?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Wilfred Chan,
Wilfred thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
It really, really, really,
really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is,
much love I'll see you soon.